we actually didn't know he was adopted
yeah none of us did we thought that his
parents were his parents for his whole
life
um but it kind of made sense because he
looks nothing like the mom and dad
whatsoever yeah uh later on in life he
found out
that uh he he was adopted
i don't know how he did but the dad
didn't tell him but he found out on his
own oh somehow
okay um he was completely normal before
has a conversation with his dad and he
and he lets him
uh know where his parents in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome
i didn't say it but i was taking it in
my head everybody knows what that [ __ ]
is man
what the [ __ ] was that uh wasn't it dave
chappelle
it was dave chappelle was making fun of
uh
was it was he a presidential candidate
oh oh that's right that's right [ __ ] was
that
ah [ __ ] i forget i bet you if i google
bia right now
[Laughter]
but dave chappelle uh made fun of it
yeah yeah yeah 2000 this is the first
thing that pops up 2004
the scream that doomed howard dean isn't
that [ __ ] funny
dog this is a wikipedia it's called it's
called the dean scream
i didn't know it had a title well the
dean scream also known as i have a
scream
was a speech delivered by vermont
governor howard dean on january 19
2004 at the valerie ballroom in west des
moines iowa
uh that night the presidential candidate
he was a presidential candidate
had had just lost the iowa caucus to
john kerry and wanted to reassure his
supporters he was going to win
the speech involved loudly listing
states he would win to a
ruckus audience before screaming
within four days it was broadcast 633
times on national views
and cables wow the audio using his
earrings of the screen was for dean's
undirectional microphone which decreased
the volume of the background noise to
the point where only dean's voice was
audible
i can't believe there's an official
write-up about this we're gonna take
wisconsin
damn it actually has a title that's
crazy i heard that should ruin his
presidential candidacy really after that
it just [ __ ] up i would feel like that
would
elevate him to another now it would i
think because the way
you get elected to be a president yeah
this type of malarkey
is the [ __ ] that'll do well that's true
i mean [ __ ] if dave chappelle's making
fun of you in this day and age man the
type of exposure you'd get
you know yeah would instantly become
relevant overnight you know
did you see this uh i started watching
uh this weird [ __ ] dock on necks it
was like the neighbor next door or
something like that have you seen that
[ __ ] no neighbor next door
i'm already no no no no no
that gives me zero incentive to watch it
then
this podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha do you hate the jitters and crash
that coffee gives you well say
no more my friends because hundreds of
thousands of people are drinking junebe
matcha not only for the health benefits
but for the caffeine boost that lasts
without the crash of coffee you can mix
it
have it hot ice cold or try it with your
favorite juices and have fun with it
remember
not all matcha is created the same and
junebe has the highest quality matcha
you can find
straight from a farm in japan
hand-picked and curated to get you the
best
quality there is no competition to get
10
off your first order of pins and packets
go to junebeshop.com
that's j-u-n-b-i shop.com and enter code
geniusbrain to get 10
off your first order that's
j-u-n-b-i-shop.com
code geniusbrain you know what's an
interesting show that uh reminds me of
when you
when you say that um it's uh
[ __ ] it's that show where uh they
interview serial killers across the
country i haven't seen that um
[ __ ] what was the name of it god i'm so
bad with these names someone might do i
just watched it yeah yeah it's on
netflix yeah it's on netflix
um it's not it's not like uh it's a
fictional show okay yeah but
the serial killers that they interview
are uh
yeah real serial killers um so you know
it's kind of the same thing how
some of these serial kills they're just
sociopaths you know they they
lie so fluidly and and mind hunter mind
hunter there you go that's the name of
it yeah
that kind of show revolves around that
whole thing is like
this guy who's kind of green in the
psychological field for the fbi so
the fbi is creating this um
they're starting to delve into the
psychological aspects of
is there something wrong with these
serial killers or are they just
killing you know um and then so once
they start delving into that
this guy starts uh interviewing these
serial killers
and then there's a fine line between you
know what they're telling as the truth
and what they're telling as lies
and he can't really distinguish that at
the beginning because he's kind of naive
right they they don't go in with an
expectation of like
yeah we gotta expect these guys to lie
and to be very charming
and and to be able to your part when the
serial killers are
very [ __ ] charming yeah it's almost
like they're consistently playing this
role
like this this acting role for the rest
of their [ __ ] lives
like they know what they need to do
to appear normal and to appear
trustworthy and credible
yeah and then they kind of uh
i guess play to the the room or or
whoever they're getting interviewed by
to basically sweet talk them and charm
them they're almost like an alien trying
to play a human
exactly yeah exactly because you know
these [ __ ] are crazy
they're [ __ ] nuts yeah there was a
podcast that uh
that would explain these it was all
different type of murders and serial
killers i forgot which one it was but my
brother also got me into that but i
stopped listening to it because it was
giving me nightmares
because it was so vivid because you're
hearing these interrogation and these
audio tapes there was this one specific
serial killer
um that would only kill i think he could
have killed his whole family
and i might be misquoting this but
there's a very specific part
um where he had a daughter and he was
like
sexually abusing this daughter oh man
but he would talk about what he would do
to
to his daughter as if it was just common
sense right
why wouldn't i do as a matter of fact as
a matter of fact
something specifically that he used to
do he would make her hold in her pee
for the longest time um and i think i
forgot what it was exactly but she would
have to pee a certain way or do
something the way he
and if she didn't or if she would pee uh
when
he wouldn't tell her to he would beat
her [ __ ] ass and he would talk about
it as if like
yeah well you know um well she was in
the bathroom
and she would you know she would
defecate or urinate
inside that without me telling to her i
[ __ ] her up
like as if as if the person he's telling
yeah
does that to their kids as well right
you know those guys
i mean look man any type of serial
killer are obviously
heinous human beings but the ones who
[ __ ] with kids that like for me that
that's like the worst of the worst
you know because you're taking these
tiny human beings
who who need to be shaped by you who
need to be nurtured and cared for by you
but you are basically destroying them
you know and and then if you kill them
that actually might be a blessing
because at least you end the [ __ ]
misery and suffering that you're putting
them through right
then if you don't kill them it was like
that case of uh with
you know gabriel hernandez remember yeah
yeah the yeah the stepfather and the
mother
just beating the [ __ ] out of that kid
they they did some [ __ ]
terrible terrible things to him that
[ __ ] was nuts just in the beginning of
the dock where they were talking about
how his head
and his skull felt like rice krispies
right it's they found cat litter in his
stomach they found a bunch of weird
things in it like paper or something
like that they would put him in the
closet yeah for the longest yeah
yeah i think for like weeks on end or
some [ __ ] right the saddest part was
when they
when he was uh the teacher who had who
knew something was wrong
but she couldn't help him out even
though she went through every single
avenue and fast to make sure that he got
the help he needed
and it was mother's day and this was two
days before he died
and everybody was making a card and she
talked to gabriel hernandez was he was
she was asking him like you don't have
to make this card for her he goes
no i want to he was super excited
writing how much he loves his mom how
pretty she is even though she's one of
the ugliest [ __ ] people
and also the one of the worst human
beings ever
right but i mean that that that proves
my point though is like
despite all the heinous things like she
did to him
there was still a love for her in in
inside of him yeah you know
and and that's the nature of a child
right it's they're like puppies
right they just they just look to you
because you're a source of like uh
care for them well anyway supposed to be
and even though you do these things to
them they still feel
love for you they still care for you i
always wondered too
what would happen to some of these kids
who survived like
these serial killers too some of them
have families that they don't they don't
[ __ ] up their family
but later on these kids like what
happens when they find out who their
parents
really are or if they did [ __ ] up stuff
you know [ __ ] up [ __ ] to them only
because
uh i know of somebody and it has nothing
to do with like serial killing right
yeah
but this person was adopted um
we actually didn't know he was adopted
yeah none of us did we thought that his
parents were his parents for his whole
life
but it kind of made sense because he
looks nothing like the mom and dad
whatsoever
yeah uh later on in life he found out
that um he he was adopted
uh i don't know how he did but the dad
didn't tell him but he found out on his
own
somehow okay um he was completely normal
before
has a conversation with his dad and he
any lets him uh
know where his parents are where his mom
is so his mom is actually in a psych
ward
so she was like like a high-end
schizophrenic i'm not sure if that's the
actual term but she deals with like
severe schizophrenia right
and him hearing that made him freak the
[ __ ] out
right and i think what i don't know what
happened to him
uh this is somebody that's not close to
me i i know of him yeah yeah um
but something happened in between that
time where something weird happened to
him
when he found out that his mom had
schizophrenia it triggered something in
his head
oh and then he started hearing voices
too wow
which i didn't know like if you're if
you're a psychiatrist or something and
you can clarify about this type of stuff
let me know because i don't i didn't
know that that kind of stuff could be
hereditary or maybe it's because he just
kind of like freaked out and psyched
himself out at this in the history
of snapped yeah so his mind ends up just
uh letting go of his career and
everything disappears
and um kind of starts doing like a lot
of religious cultist [ __ ]
okay um gave up all of his worldly
possessions yeah
everything yeah and uh later later on lo
and behold
a buddy of mine told me um uh a mutual
friend of ours told me that yo he
actually was in the hospital
i was like what happened to this dude
well he's he thought um
he told me that he thought he heard the
voice of god talking to him
and he started going getting butt naked
yeah climbing up a [ __ ] like mountain
side like one of those hillsides with
you know with the roads and [ __ ] like
that
because he kept hearing the voice of god
and so he was trying to find god
yeah and then a [ __ ] car hit him oh
my god and like broke his [ __ ] back
and everything
he can walk and [ __ ] now and yeah he's
okay i'm pretty sure he's going to have
chronic pain for the rest of his life
but the thing that triggered all that
[ __ ] was him finding out that he was
adopted which already was trauma he
didn't know
for what 20 some odd years of his life
and then on top of that found his mom
is uh is in a psych warfare that's crazy
man i mean
i can understand kind of uh going down
a dark hole after you find out that
you're adopted that's a lot to process
especially your whole life is like what
the [ __ ] yeah exactly you question
everything your whole existence
i'm not who i thought i was these people
yeah they're
they're technically your mom and dad but
not biologically
right so i'm sure man um that [ __ ] you
up on some level but then
this guy is like a step beyond that you
know in the worst way
in the worst way possible um but
schizophrenia man that that shit's real
i mean i told you the story about
uh the neighbor my parents neighbor the
kid was schizophrenic remember i think i
talked about it on the podcast before
maybe yeah this dude came like you know
um
making threats and like remember he he
called me the hacker who said i was
gonna
but that's right yeah that's right but
that [ __ ] was very real to him in his
head
and so how old was he uh he was probably
like 15 16 years old
so like when he was accusing me of that
you could see kind of like the
conviction like this dude was
convicted he started thinking
he said i was going to like that i
threatened him that i'm gonna
you know butt rape him uh very
specifically
like you may get the [ __ ] out of my face
that's exactly what my response was man
but that's the thing man it's that dude
when they hear those uh voices in their
head man that [ __ ] is very remember i
told you
this dude ended up trying to rape his
mom oh that's why yeah
yeah he cornered her in the house and
then that's what ultimately made them
send them away to get treatment i i like
how that's the last
straw it's like the [ __ ] screaming
butt rape thing wasn't the thing like
i would have been like i can't handle
this type of yeah exactly trying to rape
his mom that's [ __ ] nuts that's
that's what i heard because the thing is
like
they had some uh other people living at
the home and i was asking like so what
happened
uh to i forget what his name was i was
like what happened you know like is he
is he cool now
he's like oh no he they they sent him
away to get treatment i was like oh [ __ ]
did something bad happen
he's like yeah yeah like he he tried to
pin his mom like corner his mom
and like rape her i was like what the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] i was like did he have a
dad around
they do have a dad but the dad wasn't
around
yeah it was just a mom but i i i said it
in in the in the podcast too but her mom
the guy's mom was off too okay she she
wasn't
yes it's just she was kind of off i i
don't know in what way
but you know you know what i'm talking
about all that yeah yeah yeah when you
interact with somebody you're like oh
all right they they they don't they're
not playing with the full car today
full deck of cards i wonder how that
works because uh
my brother right now he lives
in a condo right well it's an apartment
slice condo type of thing he runs it out
from the uh from the tenant his neighbor
deals with some type of mental ailment
to the point where she's like every
night she [ __ ]
screams and starts crying for like two
three hours every night
that's and so well the good thing is is
my brother's rent got reduced by four
hundred dollars a month
just because of this yeah he's like i
gotta leave because they didn't you have
to legally
uh disclose that type of stuff before a
tenant comes in and so they're like
i was like i'm going to leave but they
can't get somebody else to move in if
if they know about that type right right
right because not only does she scream
at the top of her lungs like
crying and or whatever dude that's just
that's hard to be around man
and then because i mean it's screaming
yeah i could hear it because he will
post it on the stories like hey what do
i do by asking people what do i do about
this yeah
um she also smells really bad because
she's not bathing herself
and so when i went to go visit him in
san diego uh a couple of months ago yeah
in my mind i'm like yo how bad can this
be done it's loud like screaming
like she's she could do like death metal
rocks she lives by herself
she lives by herself so that's the thing
right so i'm trying to figure out they
said that she can't be removed
from that place i mean there's a hoa and
everything else like that but i guess
like legally she could still take care
of herself quote-unquote
how i don't know but when i walked in in
in front of his house
yeah i thought somebody [ __ ] and piss
all over the place i was like yo what
the [ __ ] is this smell
oh my god and then my brother's like
it's it's actually her house because she
leaves the windows open
oh my god so bad her house actually kind
of smells like um like
like the streets of ellie around skid
row oh my god that's how bad it smells
and so everybody's trying to figure out
how to help her yeah but they don't know
they're like well
can she ha she can't take care of
herself she has to have somebody come
and take her away
yeah or or set her to a place where she
could be taken care of but they're like
no legally she's still taking care of
herself she's paying the bills and
everything on time
so they can't do anything and she has to
want the help
at least i mean like an emergency
contact or something like just reach out
to somebody
i mean because she clearly is having
some sort of episode yeah
every [ __ ] night yeah so my brother
once saw her
in the parking lot and she was like on
the floor crying
asking for help and so my brother had to
actually help pick her up and take her
to her apartment
but she smelled like piss and [ __ ] oh so
it was he was like helping her up and
trying not to yak at the same time so i
felt
it's like you know what does he do he
said he's not going to lead this lady on
the floor yeah and he had a conversation
and talked to her
and i think at that time he assumed that
she was kind of all there
and then uh you know i think when he had
more interactions with her he found out
that she's actually a little mentally
ill
yeah i see i mean look it sounds if she
has
moments of clarity then it sounds like
it's episodes
rather than like her constant state of
being yeah but either way if she's
having
episodes on a constant basis like that
and
is screaming at the top of her lungs and
isn't even practicing basic hygiene
like hygiene you know like come on man
somebody got a helper we were talking
about this earlier in los angeles
specifically i understand why people are
just leaving to texas now at this point
specifically in los angeles like the the
homeless situation here has gotten so
terrible and out of hand
like dude uh like me and bart we went to
go eat i
want to get like some drinks in little
tokyo yeah and usually skid row
stays in a certain area if you guys
haven't been to skid row in los angeles
you don't know what it looks like it's
it's basically a hobo town yeah but it's
ridden with just drugs yeah that's not
me saying this as like a stereotype or
anything like that or making it real
this is not an assumption from the
outside like the drug problem in skid
row
is a [ __ ] issue it's gotten to the
point now where
at that area like a medieval disease
came back like leprosy or some [ __ ] like
that because
the hygiene is so bad there i i i was
actually just talking to
some of my friends earlier and i was
telling them that for the first time i'm
considering
leaving la yeah because that was exactly
it homeless problems and like
it just has become so dirty you know
well it's [ __ ] up and then what the
[ __ ] are we paying for
yeah we have the highest taxes in
california
and so like i i i want to know where
you're allocating this [ __ ] money
because this place is looking shittier
and trashier every day
yeah and i'm getting a little tired of
it yeah i mean and the pandemic didn't
help
you know it did not because uh there was
a period of time when all these
businesses were closed
and so like the encampments homeless
encampments just started migrating
into all the main areas and look i'm not
saying that
these homeless people shouldn't be
helped they need to be helped
obviously the homeless problem in la has
been
a plague for i don't for decades dog
it's hard to help someone when they're
blowing crack in somebody else's [ __ ]
like that's the uh there's this video on
twitter this is a real [ __ ]
yeah it is a video of a homeless dude
okay crack eddie blew the crack
into the other dude's [ __ ] and the
mother [ __ ] just like thank you
smoked the crack bite
and blew it in the he blew it right back
in the other dude's [ __ ] i'm like yo
i didn't know you could get high through
the anus hey man
that [ __ ] crack is a hell of a dream you
know
that that's gonna make you do some crazy
[ __ ] um
but no i i i feel it man i mean i'm i'm
around
um la all i mean that's where i live so
i'm
just driving around i'm like dude what
the [ __ ] is going on man like this
it's just getting worse and worse and
and the thing is it's like for me
i don't necessarily want to be around
that where i live
you know yeah i don't want i don't want
to be exposed to like
um that type of uh i guess
dirtiness uh like just having [ __ ]
piss and [ __ ] on on the sidewalk it's
like dude come on man you guys gotta do
something about this [ __ ] man like it's
it's just bleeding into everywhere all
the residential areas and it's like
it's problematic because uh so my when i
first came to los angeles i was
volunteering at a lot of homeless
shelters it's something that i used to
do in sacramento so i just did it over
here yeah
i mentioned the story a long time ago
but i stopped doing that [ __ ] because
the homeless dude spit
right in my [ __ ] face like it was we
were passing out [ __ ] food
yeah and the dude literally just went
too
[ __ ] spiderman web spit all over my
ice cream i was like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] but you know that's
it just kind of traumatized me a little
bit after that but uh just having a
completely into the conversation i had
with the people who were running the
thing yeah
and i was asking them it's like yeah
there's a lot of we were talking about
the homeless issue and
i'm not sure if this is true if you guys
work at a shelter but this is what was
told to me about 10 years ago
and they were telling me that in los
angeles it's not a food problem
so when you see uh homeless people here
we have
a lot of functions where homeless people
can come they know where these shelters
are they know where to get food
they can get free food easily because if
you were homeless the next day
i can give you a bunch of resources but
i can make sure that you get three hot
meals a day
or any type of meal a day you won't go
hungry yeah it's just obviously you
won't have a house to
to be at but in terms of food you'll be
fine so uh he was telling me
specifically in that area in los angeles
when people are asking you for money and
they're like i'm really hungry
they're not hungry like i know these
guys like i work here this is my living
yeah
they're using that money for drugs yeah
that's the problem for sure i guarantee
if you told them
hey i'm not gonna get you give you money
but i'll buy you a hot meal they'll tell
you to [ __ ] off right and that's
happened to me
multiple times no i know i know man like
the the drug problem is is definitely a
huge problem within the homeless
community
and also um mental issues right
because a lot of the funding when it was
cut for like these mental mental
institutions
these people who were getting treated
had nowhere to go when was that that was
like what the the
late eighties early nineties in the
eighties yeah i forgot what that [ __ ]
was but i i
i've heard of it i haven't really looked
into it but it was something where
they just started sending people who
were mentally ill out into the streets
yeah they're still
there's nowhere to go you know where to
go man uh once once funding disappeared
for those places um
yeah where are you going to send those
people right and then so
i think that that makes up a bulk of the
homeless community
is drug abusers and people with
uh you know mental issues mental
diseases blowing cracking [ __ ]
that's exactly what's happening dude
yeah i mean even little tokyo man
there's
there's some uh there's this lady who
used to
always go around there she looks like a
normal person
but then she always has the same story
like down to the
last detail of why are you talking about
the are you talking about the late age
lady
i think the white lady the white league
the blonde one right yeah yeah yeah
y'all
if this lady called to me one more time
she got aids yeah i'm like
you listen you've been living with aids
for damn you're [ __ ] 10 years now
did you see you know the other dude with
the with the tattoo on his head oh yeah
yeah you know that guy right yeah
[ __ ] man so you know the same people
this
let me tell you something listen i'm not
a homeless person right but i know i
have tacked about how to ask money yeah
aids lady is the most hilarious lady of
all because she has no tact
she just comes up she goes excuse me sir
yeah i have aids
and i'm like yo what the [ __ ] what yo
ease me into the conversation
and that's all she says and then she
just asked for money after i'm like you
know you could have just asked for money
i don't need to know the aids part
you know which you don't have yeah you
know yeah that's and that's what i'm
saying there's some of these people
who've recited their story
uh over and over again and they try to
appear as normal as possible
and make it seem like they just really
need a little bit of money a little bit
of help from you
but clearly that that money is that
number tattoo guy i
heard his spiel so often when i was a
little tokyo all the time excuse me sir
i just got out of the
out of prison a couple of days ago as
you can see from the tattoo from my
forehead there's a reason why i can't
have a job
he did that [ __ ] i gave him five bucks
once he forgot he asked me for money
he turned around and he's like excuse me
sir i just got out of jail a couple i
was like
i was like i just gave you five bucks he
goes all right
same [ __ ] yeah this is a couple days ago
i'm like bro i don't know a couple days
down
yeah so that like that's the thing man
it's like for me you know
i was born and raised here and so like
you kind of get desensitized to that
[ __ ]
you see a lot of the cases where like
when you do try to help them out
that they don't want the food that
they're saying that they need the money
for
yeah and it's like okay well if that's
the [ __ ] case because i buy
i'll buy them like a subway sandwich or
something no i mean i've seen you do it
too
you know um and so like
i would say one out of ten times they'll
they'll actually take you up on that
offer it's very few information yeah
yeah
and then so like if that's the case it's
like come on man you know where that
money's gonna
where that money's gonna go bro there's
a kid too that's actually in k-town
he's like this young black kid uh he's
probably in his like what mid-20s now
maybe he was like 18 at the time but uh
i was at subway and you know like this
is when i first came to la i didn't have
a lot of [ __ ] money yeah
and so i remember this guy number one
i didn't like being touched if i don't
[ __ ] know you oh that's like the
worst thing so
i'm about to go into the subway there's
no grabs on my shoulder yeah right and
i'm like
what the [ __ ] right yeah hey sir like
it's like yo can i
can you buy me like a sandwich or
whatever this guy's a good looking young
18 year old dude yeah
and i'm like i was like number one don't
touch me yeah but
number two it's like yeah i'll get you a
sandwich like it's not a problem yeah
it's coming in
and i just you know i think when i look
at somebody like him and he's very
capable right and i was like hey bro i'm
gonna buy you a sandwich in a meal but i
want to ask you a question right
and i was like you look at me right i'm
like if you don't know this
but i'm really broke right now i don't
actually have a lot of [ __ ] money
yeah you know which is why i'm also
eating at the subway with you
i'ma get you the sandwich yeah but i see
you're a good-looking dude you're 18
years old
you look fine like what's your story
right he's like yeah i just i dropped
out of high school and you know i just i
don't want to work a job i don't want to
do anything so i'm just like out here
living my life
and i'm like i'm on a second man and so
i looked at him i was like so
so you think it's fair for me where i'm
barely making ends meet barely being
able to pay my rent
you know trying to make it out here in
the city that i just moved into you
you'll take my money
because you don't want to work and i
should buy you a sandwich when i'm over
here
struggling to pay for my own stuff yeah
right he got really [ __ ] quiet yeah
i'm like so you don't want to work
simply because you don't want to work
yeah you just want to be lazy i was like
that's
it yeah i was like you know i'll be real
with you man like that's kind of [ __ ]
up
you know that you would take my money to
feed yourself when i have to work my ass
off for my paycheck yeah
you know and uh i remember after i said
that this one got dead quiet he goes hey
man you ain't gotta buy me a sandwich
and that's like that i was like no no
i'm gonna buy you the sandwich
yeah i mean he's like nah you don't
gotta tell us like no i'm gonna get you
the sandwich
you should have told them well i was
just gonna get a six inch for me a six
for you but i guess i mean the foot
locked do it again
was like oh [ __ ] this one just lectured
me man and i'm like nah i'm gonna get
you this sandwich but
i bought him the sandwich and it's funny
because he's actually at he ended up
going towards that 7-eleven
near uh not near chapman but near a blue
cafe blue
that you know everybody holds the road
but he became a door-opening dude
over there but the funny thing is he
remembered me yeah because i gave him
that that talk
yeah he just never asked me for money
just open the doors like what's up man
he's opening the door for me
because it sucks you know what i'm
looking at i'm like yo it's cool to live
your life like that but i'm just curious
when someone i see a good-looking young
stronger no it's not cool to live your
life like that bro if you're
if you're fully capable if if you're
if you don't have anything like impeding
you from from like
getting a job and being able to support
yourself
and your only excuse is i'm just lazy
and i don't want to do that
that's not cool bro that is not cool
yeah you're spitting in the face of
everybody else
who like is pulling tooth and nail to
make it work for themselves yeah you
know what i mean and then and
and you're leeching off of that yeah
like those people
i don't feel should get any compassion
from uh people who are supporting
themselves
because again if you're able and and the
opportunities are there now i'm not
saying you're gonna have
like a comfortable lavish life but i'm
saying you could do enough for yourself
to get a roof over your head some
clothes on your back
and in a hot meal on the table and if
you choose not to do that again
only because you're lazy bro you don't
deserve anything from anyone yeah it's
weird because that option is always
there and i've
i've always i've always kind of like i
don't want to say scrutinize people on
this type of stuff
but it's more like because i know how
hard my parents work to
get their paycheck right and you know
somebody i've been asked this question a
lot it's you know what would you have
done
without youtube i was like i would have
figured it out exactly i would have
worked a job
anything i would work four five six jobs
it doesn't [ __ ] matter yeah if
there's a
if if i need to figure out what my means
to an end is yeah
and so when people think like oh when
this whole space explodes
what would you do [ __ ] i got skills son
i'll do something
you know what i mean i'll i'll figure it
out i'll pop blocking santa monica
[ __ ] i'll be out here all in
silver
doing the robot like getting dollars
i'll figure that [ __ ] out dude like
don't worry and i have no shame too if i
ended up to a point where people were
like oh my god like you lost everything
so i guess i got to start from the
ground up again yeah exactly that's what
it is you might feel embarrassed for me
i don't have to feel embarrassed for
myself
because i know my situation yeah and
when you come from nothing
it is what it is that's life dude right
for sure and that's what i'm saying is
that
look you're first of all uh blessed
to be born in this country right i mean
despite
the problems here let's be real man
versus a lot of other countries out
there in the
euro ladder to climb that's very that
you're very capable of climbing exactly
exactly america will give you uh a
leg up over a lot of um other countries
and the opportunities that are available
to the average person in other countries
and then so to have that and then to
just basically be like ah
nah you know i don't i don't ever want
to do anything and i just want to
freeload and i just want to leech
it's like well then yeah you deserve to
[ __ ] be on the street
and you deserve to have nothing it's
it's hard to tell that to
i think to a lot of uh immigrants right
asian african latin it doesn't matter
right
yeah immigrants have a hard time
empathizing with people who grew up in
this country that know the language that
understand the system
um to a certain extent right obviously
there's other factors like racism and
you know systemic racism and stuff like
that but it's sometimes hard just to
give a perspective for other people when
they don't understand like why
immigrants don't get it
is because they're seeing it through
their lens it's like i came into this
country
didn't know the [ __ ] language yeah
and i and i figured it out yeah i had no
money
no money did [ __ ] three jobs blue
collar work
just to get by yeah and then you hear
somebody who's and you see somebody
begging for money you hear that they
speak perfect english
they're smoking cigarettes they're
having beer and then an immigrant person
is like
the [ __ ] do you have this [ __ ] for this
is luxury [ __ ] you get to have that only
because it's a luxury
yeah and so it's it's hard to empathize
for people who came from nothing
specifically if you're talking to like a
refugee like for sure
like like refugees who escape war-torn
countries yeah
like i like my friend abinuin she's a
she's a one fc fighter right
she said this this funny ass it was
funny but it's really true yeah
where she would hear people growing up
and she she's a vietnamese refugee
and she would hear people like
complaining in oakland about you know
this like
oh like my [ __ ] ac is not working
she's like you guys have ac
you know what i mean she came from
vietnam yeah she goes hold on you have
to
you guys got ac yeah what the [ __ ] what
is ac
i lived in a hut like what the [ __ ] i
lived in a [ __ ] village are you
kidding me right now yeah
so you know that perspective flip was a
huge thing like so
can you really complain to b about you
not being able to do this stuff she came
from a place where
[ __ ] electricity wasn't an option you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah so it's a
weird concept no for sure it's a
different perspective when when you're
coming from a situation like that but
i i you know you can't instill like
um i guess a will into people you can't
you can't
instill uh that type of like a
motivation
if they don't have it and so it's like
hey man if that's what you want for
yourself
then so be it but don't expect anything
either you know see that was the thing
too like
um we were having a conversation about
this where we were saying
well i've i've kind of started to figure
this stuff out too i think when i was
younger
i think a lot of young people can
understand this we when we're younger we
tend to get upset at other people who
aren't living the same life that we are
right
but there's a flaw in that mentality
because
instead of saying like oh if you don't
if you're not on my level [ __ ] you it
should be more like
you should learn how to compartmentalize
your friendships right yeah understand
what this who this person is and
understand where they're going to go
yeah you shouldn't be upset at somebody
else for not being able to achieve the
stuff that you think that they can
achieve because now you're just being
their parent it is not your job the
first
parent for sure and it's it's better to
help save your friendship and your
relationships with people by
understanding their capabilities and
expecting what you can expect from them
yeah
yeah so because you know like we've
talked about a mutual friend too who
highly talented can do whatever the [ __ ]
he wants but
in his mind from our perspective from
what we've seen it's like
he will choose to do stuff that's very
comfortable the way that he wants to do
it
simply because he doesn't he the
discomfort bothers him
yeah him a lot right yeah and for us we
can be like yo [ __ ] you you should do a
lot better but we're not his [ __ ]
parents yeah
this guy's a good person yeah he's fun
to be around and when you kind of
encapsulate your friendship in that it
allows you to navigate it better so
because why should i
stress myself out for sure you know
putting this pressure on him
for [ __ ] what yeah you know i mean as
a as a friend you know who who cares for
their friend and loves their friend
there's nothing wrong
with like you know giving your opinion
but then at the end of the day
um they're they're a grown ass adult
they're gonna have to make their own
choice you know
you can always provide another
perspective and and like kind of uh
paint another avenue for them that that
might be an option
but then it's ultimately them up to them
whether or not they want to take that
yeah they're going to work hard in the
way that they want to work hard yeah
whether i agree with it or not it's
really none of my [ __ ] babies yeah
exactly
exactly my [ __ ] baby yeah exactly you
know i think the hard part is like you
said
is where when i think
they're if if it's not this person but
if let's say we've had these type of
relationships before where some whether
a friendship ends up to the point where
the person is being such a [ __ ] loser
that they continually want to take from
their friends they take take take and
take when they have a solution
when they can do stuff on their own but
they rather take from you rather than
doing it see that's when the line gets
crossed exactly
yeah if you if you just want to do you
and without it really affecting anybody
else that's right
yeah that's your progressive if you want
a a handout
and like you know be an opportunist
you're a freeloader yeah exactly you're
a [ __ ] freelancer
then that's when it's like all right man
i'm done with your ass
you know because it's hard right like
let's say you have somebody who
uh like you have a friend who
consistently asks you for money all the
time
but then you ask him yo what did you do
this way he's like i was just playing
games all day
yeah [ __ ] you chillin yeah [ __ ] you my
money ain't [ __ ] chillin
in my
but that that's that's the part where
that line gets crossed a lot because now
you're choosing to be
quote unquote lazy you're choosing to
take from the people around you right
even when you have the ability to do it
for yourself yeah and that's where
that's where that [ __ ] becomes a little
weird because i i i genuinely tend not
to lend money
yeah i only give money so it's like you
i know you're a good person you're in a
rough spot
i'll give you this thousand dollars i
don't expect it to be returned back yeah
but that starts coming around three
times yeah four times it's like
now you're trying to get killed right
now you try to get stabbed dude yeah
now i cut out people like that from my
life like a while back man
cause once i recognize it i will give
him the benefit of doubt like okay
just because you know we're friends and
we have that history and relationship
i give you the benefit of the doubt
right but then
i think beyond the second time that's
when it's like okay that that's it
i have a mutual friend with somebody
else this guy is like the ultimate
[ __ ] freeloader
uh i think he owes my friend close to
like twenty thousand dollars holy [ __ ]
it's it's some ridiculous [ __ ] number
over time yeah and you know when you're
doing well
you want to be able to help your friends
just because of you know whatever the
history that you have
and you want to be a down-ass friend
absolutely but that starts to accumulate
after a while right yeah
and then lo and behold a lot of us found
out through other mutual friends like
the reason why he was borrowing money
wasn't because some bad [ __ ] happened or
things about
things that were out of his control the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] has a gambling i knew
it i [ __ ]
right and this is the [ __ ] that pisses
me off the most right yeah
gambling [ __ ] issue but on uh
twitter and then instagram it's like you
know you owe
20 g's to your homies and [ __ ] like that
yeah
but you're [ __ ] flying the new jays
that you got these new clothes and then
you're putting up inspirational quotes
about
hustling and working hard i will [ __ ]
kill you the worst of the worst
you know what i'm gonna be like your
[ __ ] schizophrenic i will [ __ ] you
dude
you best believe i did say it i will
[ __ ] you
i will confuse my own sexuality
just to prove a [ __ ] point to you
like to quote mike tyson i'm gonna [ __ ]
you in the ass do you love me you
f word no but yeah those
those people are the worst of the worst
i've had experiences with those type of
people too
and um it's not and it's like when
once you see it it's just so disgusting
you know what i mean like i feel
dirty i feel dirty inside like that i
considered you a friend
and i cared for you and and i provided
for you in a way that
you needed because you needed help you
needed help
and then and then turns out you're just
a [ __ ] scumbag
you know you you just you were just
[ __ ] trying to lie or hide things
and it's like man i wanna i wanna i wish
i could sit down and talk to people and
understand what's going on no point no
[ __ ] point because they don't have
that perspective
they don't have that sense you know for
them even if you tell them hey what
you're doing is wrong
it doesn't process it doesn't process
like that to them
for them it's just like so
yeah you know they're like i told you
i'm gonna pay you back like what are you
tripping about
you said that 10 years ago this is why
the italian mafia is around
this is why you need a guy named vinnie
to come with the club and start breaking
kneecaps
where's my [ __ ] money yeah hey
where's my [ __ ] money
what the [ __ ] my money huh yeah does
my club gotta talk to your two kneecaps
and have a rough conversation with you
but yeah man the the best thing to do is
just to cut people like
i mean it's even worse when you got
family like that too
you know family yeah like i've had some
dog
money always [ __ ] up korean family for
sure
i don't know what it is about korean
people and i i could i'm obviously
cause i'm a korean person but i had a
situation with a family member
who listen i can't even wrap my head
around this because
so essentially what happened with this
family member uh my parents my dad as
the oldest son
has been taking care of his parents
right when my parents first came to this
country
uh as the oldest son my dad had to make
ends meet and i remember
um he obviously had to pay for the
apartment and also other stuff
now originally him and his uh
siblings would split it up right well
one of his siblings
later on because my my grandparents um
physical state was getting really [ __ ]
up
somebody had to take care of my grandpa
couldn't live at the house
by himself yeah so originally what would
what happened was that uh one of his
relatives decided
to take her uh take him in and they
decided that it was too much so my dad
was like it's okay just bring him over
to the house right because i lived there
too so i could help out making meals or
whatever
so he was getting a uh
social security check right for
i forgot how many x amount of months lo
and behold six
six seven eight months or it could even
be it could have been even a little
longer we weren't seeing any checks
right and mind you these checks that
were coming in and we weren't spending
it we're buying him clothes we're buying
him food any type of food that he wanted
to eat
we were going to get it for him right uh
none of these none of these checks were
coming in
and so my dad just you know he's busy
doing his own thing he's a pastor he
runs his own business he's doing all
this other stuff
he asked me to go take care of it make
some phone calls so i started making
phone calls
and asking where the checks were they're
like yo the checks have been cashed i'm
like
how can the checks be cash we haven't
received any of them right
so their that [ __ ] apparently they
called and they got those checks
rerouted to their house and they were
using my grandpa's social security
checks
for whatever [ __ ] reason oh man and
could you imagine
the [ __ ] rage my dad had yeah because
it's not like you're taking money from
us you're taking money from your own
parent
yeah dude who's [ __ ] helpless like
exactly
so my dad's you know paying all the
stuff out of his poc which isn't a
problem because he's dead
that's the point that's like grandpa's
money exactly you know
yeah and so having to have and i
couldn't first of all it wasn't an
absorbent amount of money it wasn't a
lot it was maybe 600 bucks a month right
what the [ __ ] were you thinking and were
you not thinking that we were gonna find
out
and i had to deal with the stuff and it
came to the point where our other
relatives were like
yo why are you guys so upset at her we
couldn't even say anything
because we didn't want them to look at
this person like a piece of [ __ ] yeah
because we're trying to save face for
the whole family and
i just don't want to deal with drama
yeah and so you know we're just like ah
they just did some weird [ __ ]
yeah yeah still haven't told them till
this day about what the specific
relative did
yeah but that's [ __ ] up you literally
stole money from your parents dude
that's a huge scumbag [ __ ] yeah
oh man i yeah i got plenty of stories
like that with my family too bro
like uh when my grandpa in korea passed
away
uh in his will he left behind land and i
think uh you know on my mom's side
there's like
uh six she has five other siblings
but anyway the oldest one is a son right
and he actually did really well for
himself because when he was growing up
since he was a
firstborn son like my grandparents
they did anything and everything yeah to
like
push him right his education his college
um and you gotta understand like they
were out in the [ __ ] countryside they
they they weren't they weren't they
weren't wealthy they were poor you know
with a big family
but he was a priority and so long story
short he ended up becoming
pretty damn [ __ ] wealthy i think he
ended up becoming like the president of
a major bank in korea and all this [ __ ]
yeah but it's amazing when the when it
came time
to splitting the will and splitting the
land he was trying to take it all for
himself
what the [ __ ] man it's like dude you're
the last [ __ ] person who needs it
yeah you know you're you got younger
siblings who are actually [ __ ]
struggling who could use it
it's like you're trying to so there was
this whole [ __ ] mess with that like
fighting going on with the siblings
and then like the grandpa situation you
mentioned
so my grandpa um he uh
passed away i think it was a 90. you
know god rest his soul but
maybe about when he was 86
87 he met this like random [ __ ]
pastor on the street i don't really know
how right but he was maybe like
young 40s late 30s type of dude and
he started living with my [ __ ]
grandpa at his senior citizen community
what the [ __ ] how they can't no so so i
asked my
i thought i thought that that guy had a
relation in our fact like he was a
distant cousin or something like that
and so my grandpa was just taking him in
because he just got here to the cu
i thought it was something yeah it turns
out this guy was a complete [ __ ]
but i don't know i really don't know um
and then i guess
he met my grandpa somewhere and they got
to talking and he needed a place to stay
so my grandpa
was just like hey you could stay with me
so he was pretty much
living off of my grandpa and i'm pretty
sure he was spending
his social security checks too and the
[ __ ] that will [ __ ] piss me off is
like this dude would come to like our
family
get-togethers as a pastor yeah he would
drive my grandpa
okay you know to these uh get-togethers
and once i heard see for
for like a while i didn't have any
feelings about it because i just assumed
he was like a distant family member yeah
once i found out he wasn't though i was
not happy
with this dude coming around man i
wanted to say something
my parents are like hey your grandpa's
old
like he's he's like you know obviously
content with having him around just it's
i guess
for them they just saw it as him having
company yeah because my grandpa refused
to live
you know with uh with my parents or like
with his uh
other son and then so it's just like
yeah let him let him just have a
companion you know
and it's like yeah maybe he might not be
doing the the most ethical [ __ ]
but he's getting something yeah yeah but
i'm like dude [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're gonna meet a stranger on the
on the [ __ ] street
and live with the dude and my grandpa's
place was a one bedroom so i don't even
know what the living arrangement was
this whole place
was freeloading off a centurion dude
this guy's a 100 years old
are you [ __ ] nuts what are you guys
talking about yeah i was like dude what
the [ __ ] is up with this guy man
and like how do you [ __ ] not have
shame like to to
to do that [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's weird i don't want why does this
every [ __ ] korean person get con dude
my dad has a lot of trust issues yeah
but you know what the good thing is i
feel like because
he was so hyper cautious because of the
uh of
the terrible things that happened to him
it made me a lot more
cautious as well in a good way yeah
where if i don't like somebody or i said
something is wrong
i'd say not to you could even ask the
closest people to me like
90 percent of the time 95 of the time
i'm usually right about that person
because i've seen those behaviors yeah
yeah yeah it's a red flag yeah there's a
red flag it's like specific behaviors
that i've seen
uh my dad go through and he made me sure
that to kind of watch out for these
things right
and the interesting thing about snakes
and and people who backstab you too
they're the most likable human beings
they don't they don't come into your
circle or your group because they're
terrible people it's not there in the
front
you can kind of smell it on them there's
something off about how they behave
towards you or they open up to you too
fast yeah and it's like
what do you want and it makes you kind
of almost sound like a very pessimistic
person yeah but it's not that it's i've
been around people enough to know
that most people don't give that much on
first meeting somebody without expecting
something
for sure man for sure unless they're
balling out of their [ __ ] mind
you're just a maggot and you're just a
blip yeah in the world right no i mean
look man
sometimes people you just have kind and
giving people
yeah and like you know i really
appreciate when i come across those type
of people because they're far and few
now
right but at the same time there's a
fine line between a person who's just
giving and kind
and a person who's giving because they
like you said wants something in return
or is looking for a come up
yeah it's just being opportunistic you
know um
especially in a place like la right i
mean i'm sure you've had your fair share
of dealing with scumbags here
this is this city is very odd too
because
and i and i always want to kind of
reference or encompass
this this piece of advice for people who
move to los angeles because sometimes i
get
i get annoyed of people who will come
into this city and they get upset at
other people for doing the same thing
that they're doing right
so for example like you'll hear a lot of
young creators they talk about this [ __ ]
and this is like young creators that are
probably
you know they're starting to pop off or
whatever and they go yo man i
like uh there's no real people out in la
like you can't make good friends out
here blah blah blah blah and i'm like
hold on a second
pump your brakes what did you come to la
for and if i asked them they go i came
to la so i wanted to make it i wanted to
network
so you didn't come here for friendships
you got what you came here for
you've got you came here for
acquaintances that you could leech and
mooch off
right and they did exactly same thing
back to you exactly you have
no right to say yeah i don't have real
friends when you didn't come here for
out here with that friendship yeah what
the [ __ ] you expect is gonna happen you
know what i mean like if you
if you wanna you know build a
relationship and cultivate a
relationship
you can't approach it from a standpoint
of i want something from this person
it has to be like yo this person's cool
i vibe with him
i want to you know cultivate a french i
want to cultivate this friendship with
him
and then certain actions come with that
mindset then if your thing is oh
you know this person could get me some
views or this person could get me some
likes
come on man what the [ __ ] you you know
if your approach is like that and it's
that
superficial they're not as dope as i
thought they were yeah like hold on a
second
yeah you guys just collapsed on a video
you dumb [ __ ] what did you think you're
gonna know who this person was
but yeah man there's there's so many of
those types of people man
and like well i can't speak for other
major cities because i haven't spent
enough time
in other major cities but in la anyway
you got a lot of creators here you got a
lot of musicians you got
a lot of actors or aspiring you know and
man you you just come across some pretty
[ __ ] human beings man yeah los angeles
has a very interesting vibe when it
comes to that stuff like uh
like i love the city you know i've lived
here now for what 11 years yeah so you
know it's
it's god damn yeah 11 years now man yeah
so it's become home yeah you know yeah
i mean i still have love from my
hometown sacramento right but you know
i've lived here for a fat chunk of my
life now
you know so much so that you're a laker
fan now absolutely
[Laughter]
the only reason why i was having lakers
one was because of kobe i don't know
because kobe just passed i was like
i want that ring for them for sure you
know for sure sacramento
like i gotta vote for somebody yeah yeah
everybody was hyped about that win dude
i mean look it's it's great to to get a
chip
um in the year that kobe passed for sure
i think i think that's fantastic but
you know it's always going to be an
asterisk championship you know
and like some people think the feat is
greater that it happened during
a time of like civil unrest social
injustice pandemic like all this [ __ ]
going on
and to an extent i i i do
um agree that that's a big factor yeah
uh but
i don't know if i could necessarily say
it made it harder because the thing is
not all the players were there
not all the teams were there and then so
and it was like super
uh condensed the the remainder of the
season
so i'm just like uh i mean it was hard
for me to watch basketball this season
yeah dude it just
there's no crowd yeah it doesn't feel
the same it got to the point where they
started uh
implementing crowd noise yeah yeah it
was like
ah oh doesn't feel yeah
exactly like dog the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
now i
i feel like certain sports uh without a
crowd
it makes it less entertaining but then
something like mma
it makes it so much more raw yeah
because you could hear skulls crack
you're like oh
that hurt well that's what i'm saying
when people talk about like
yo man i can't believe like that fool
got knocked out so easy yeah i don't
think you
understand those gloves are about like
an inch thick the only thing it's doing
is protecting the fire
hands it's not protecting their face
you're just getting sucked up
yeah like legit hard socks right
and that's why i'm always saying like if
you're a ufc fan or anything else just
try training a little bit
and then it'll help you understand the
sport a little more right i think that
was a good idea for people to understand
how how hard they're working because you
could hear them breathe super heavy and
like oh that's
that wall work and that groundwork that
they're doing right now is exhausting
yeah because before you just hear a
crowd scream and you're mad at them
right
for not doing anything and i'm like look
at them yeah now it's so much more
intimate
you know and it's like you definitely
have
a newfound respect for the fighters
because it's like did you just see
ferguson take that hit from kg and just
[ __ ] be completely unfazed
yeah like the 90 of people will be
knocked out on their [ __ ] ass cold
you know
but it's like whole because you hear it
you feel it because you hear it you know
and so i got more i mean i've always
been a ufc fan but like
during the pandemic i became more
invested in it because it feels
so much well it was the only sport
around for the hottest time
the ufc yeah did such a great job in
capitalizing on that they're like
absolutely you guys don't have sports
i'm the only sport that you have
blew up props to dana white man when he
got it done yeah when he first started
talking about hey we're gonna
we're gonna be the first organization to
come back
i was like okay i i admire the
motivation and the fire you got but like
realistically how what
how can you get this done he got it done
and then everybody took
his blueprint and they started opening
up other sports what they did in the
[ __ ] bubble
in uh abu dhabi yeah it's crazy man
it's [ __ ] nuts and the fact that
they've had zero infections
yeah you know since they started this
run they've they've done a great job
and they get tested multiple times
before you even get to be yeah right
like in the moment they find that you
have it
yeah you get the [ __ ] out right right
you're gone so so i think it's
they uh he clarified that of like people
have tested before they got there
and tested positive but nobody once
they're in the bubble yeah nobody's
tested pod and they're constantly
testing throughout the whole thing
throughout the whole thing yeah but then
i i watch kind of like the insider
episodes on youtube and [ __ ] and then
like kind of what they got going on
there is just like
dude that kind of seems like a unique
experience that would be fun to have now
you're on an island by yourself why not
by yourself but it's like what maybe 200
300 people there yeah that's it yeah and
then you got like the
the service and then like everything
that the restaurants and the food that's
all
available to you if you stayed with that
one girl that could have been your whole
life dude and would you [ __ ] yeah
i gotta breathe you always gonna come
back to that
you didn't have to imagine no that could
have been you
oh man it's okay i missed that girl i
think her name was sarah or something
like that i forgot her name but i miss
you dude
actually i didn't even know she was she
was born like that until you guys broke
up
she was so good at hiding it well she
didn't really she was just really sweet
girl you just never would think it
yeah yeah i mean uh it was just one of
those things where it's like it wasn't
flaunted you know the yeah
so if you're just outside of looking in
you would never be able to tell oh
it's not like one of these people who
are [ __ ] pulling up in like a bentley
you know and then we'll could if she
wanted to
i mean sure you see all those
international students 19 years i
remember when uh
you were doing your your uh your drips
and squirrels thing
oh yeah and then the i think it was the
one of the grand opening week right
about those chinese fobs that were wrong
bro i was like yo
there's a [ __ ] mclaren yeah there's a
[ __ ] bentley
and first of all let's talk about that
mclaren where that kid scraped the [ __ ]
out of it
i was like dog are you [ __ ] nuts yeah
they
but and they were like 19. they look
like [ __ ] babies
i'm like holy [ __ ] bro you guys are
driving like 150 thousand dollars
i appreciate you for being a fan but
[ __ ] you man
whatever your family's doing let me get
a let me get involved in that bro
so i was talking to uh one of my friends
and her
her dad does uh a lot of like real
estate [ __ ] and stop investments or
whatever but
he's a chinese guy and then um i was
asking him i don't think i was asking i
think he brought up about
a lot of new money and a lot of these
properties being bought up
he kind of alluded to the fact that i
guess something that happened in china
where you know
these villages were uh gathering all
their money up to buy property and land
and where these governments were
subsidizing and buying the land off the
people
so these these are like villagers who
save up their whole money and check like
whatever hundreds of them yeah and they
just cumulatively combine it together
and they're all cashed
out yeah so they ended up being [ __ ]
millionaires that's why
you have these quote unquote mainland
chinese yeah yeah yeah who are who
made overnight money success they just
had to
you know kind of grind out for a bit
yeah and they just foresaw what was
going to happen yeah
and so this whole village is just
balling now millions of [ __ ] dollars
yeah they don't know what to do with it
and they've never been
in a society where or in an area where
wealth like that was common
right so you have people like the
disneyland people who are [ __ ] in
bags and throwing it into a [ __ ] bush
pissing into a bottle and just you know
throwing it off to the side
that's why they had to start uh having
etiquette classes yeah
for you know people traveling to foreign
countries yeah stop
spitting everywhere huh don't spit
inside the [ __ ] restaurant
let's start with that yeah don't lay out
a newspaper
in the plane and have your [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the middle of the scene
i ca i still can't believe that happened
yeah yeah there was an article where
this
lady had her kid in the middle of a
[ __ ] flight this is like them in
first class by the way or some [ __ ] like
that yeah
she lays out a newspaper and the kids
start [ __ ] on the newspaper in the
middle of the flight
but you know what i'm saying like when
you when you're coming from the
countryside and
yeah baby yeah exactly like
it you're just doing what you normally
do but
you've never been taught or been exposed
to like
you remember uh what's that one
restaurant that shirts that that serves
the kaibichi
yeah yeah there's this one like mainland
chinese fob dude yeah is actually a
kind of like a higher class like korean
restaurant yeah right it's super nice
has some of the best
kai bichim and kaibijim is uh braised
beef short ribbon soy and sugar and
everything else
this [ __ ] had a seat on the foot
on the seat like this
elbow out yeah chewing so [ __ ] loud
i'm on the other side and you see this
and rice flying out of his [ __ ] mouth
dude
wearing like a [ __ ] balenciaga
t-shirt and all this gaudy
expensive [ __ ] doesn't know how to wear
it type of [ __ ] yeah
chewing so [ __ ] loud somebody
actually came up to him and told him to
close his [ __ ] mouth yeah
it was that loud hey man like honestly a
lot of that new
money don't got r don't really have
class in etiquette you know
it could be me too though you wait for
me to get money if somebody tells me to
shut my [ __ ] mouth i'll buy you bro
get out of my face right now i got that
[ __ ] you money
yeah i'm gonna have you [ __ ] smoke a
crackpot
in my house and you're gonna enjoy it
you're gonna enjoy it yeah uh but yeah i
mean i've i've definitely had run-ins
with uh those type of tourists
no respect for personal space whatsoever
they
invade like at the airport yeah yeah bro
like their face is on your shoulder i'm
like
yo what the [ __ ] back up bro when we
were when i was going to japan yeah and
we're all waiting in line to go into
customs right
there's this family trying to just cut
every i thought they had family members
they were trying to cut everybody i put
my suitcase in front i said
no because it was like 12 people bro
i know they they don't even care like
they don't even seem
ashamed yeah and this lady was trying to
move around i looked at her i said
no yeah you need to go back and when the
airport just came over and saw and
they're like
oh i was like can we help you i was like
they're trying to cut all of us right
now and they sent
the [ __ ] family of 12 all the way to
the back you know what i noticed was
that
um the moment you speak english to them
though it kind of
shakes them up yeah yeah because they
assume that you're just like you know an
asian maybe korean chinese whatever
right but
you're not from america but then as soon
as they know that you're american
and you say english speak english to
them they're just kind of like oh
yeah like okay the audacity dude you've
been waiting here for [ __ ] an hour
and a half and you're gonna cut 12
and the thing is like people nobody
knows what's really going on yeah so
they kind of get away with it yeah but
then i know what's up like i've seen
this [ __ ] i'm like you're not gonna i'm
not gonna wait here another hour because
12 of your family members want to do
this [ __ ]
bro [ __ ] out of your dude definitely
the getting on the airplane with uh that
is is pretty not not a fun experience
they got the [ __ ] gucci bags and
everything with the gold chain i know
exactly what you are bro
[ __ ] to the back yeah you're balling now
yeah like i don't give a [ __ ] about you
yeah you are not poor anymore yeah it's
like ridiculous
but you know what are you gonna do man
like for them it's just like that
they came into that money by um
unique circumstances in the country and
then they
were like well what are we going to do
let's travel let's let's get out of this
country and let's go see
you know what's out there money like
that one day man i just want to wake up
one day and just be like
i literally don't have to do anything if
i don't want to that would be nice and
you know what it doesn't even have to be
like
i need to have an extravagant lifestyle
even if i could just
uh travel um very like bare minimum
in in the bare minimum way i would be
ecstatic
i'd be sorry hey y'all make sure you
donate to us and then i'll show you what
i'll do with this money
which really isn't much i just wanna if
you guys make me
retire in the next two years like rich
like that
i will uh audition to be a jabberwocky
until i get in
[Laughter]
like i got nothing better to do so like
yo bro
hey man you're not gonna make it i was
like i made a promise i told these
people retire me
i'm auditioning every [ __ ] year doug
over here just [ __ ]
body waving my way into this [ __ ]
position [ __ ] oh yeah i would if
i if i could do that if i if i could
retire
uh anytime soon you know like let's say
from now
and next five years i would just travel
honestly
i would just i would just uh probably
travel for
at least a few years and then uh if i
happen to get tired of that which i
don't think i would figure out what to
do after that but
i want to see and experience so many
different cultures
and foods around the world but it's time
you know
and what do you need to have more time
you need more money
exactly [ __ ] guys well that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
uh we every thursdays and sundays you
can find edric at ed2 and also
secret says a secret society that's
i e t s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y go ahead and
cop that [ __ ] gear that hat on him is
from secret society yes sir
this cat right here is also secret
society and brain 15 for first time
customers
get that frame 15. yup this
shirt that you see me wear consistently
because it feels so good yeah that's
really comfortable yeah i love this
lucky shirt but we'll see you all next
time all right y'all peace